hi I'm Pokey and this is the wired
autocomplete interview and I'm really
nervous
well been Googling and I'm about to find
out
[Music]
what Pokey what is pokey
um sometimes I don't even know I'm a
content creator streamer gamer vlogger I
kind of do a little bit of everything I
am me she her yeah so actually the
reason this is my name is because
obviously gaming I play a lot of Pokemon
and my name is Iman so it's supposed to
be a play on words that's why it's
actually supposed to be pronounced
Pokemon but I understand in English this
just reads as Pokey main so I'm never
mad at people when they pronounce it
that way I'm like call me whatever you
want as long as it's nice
what made Pokemon famous streaming
for sure 100 streaming I've been
streaming since I was 17. it's been like
nine years I started doing it as a hobby
in high school and then it became my
full-time job and then I started making
content on all platforms and that's how
people know me I guess what is Pokemon's
valorant rank my Peak was Immortal
but that was about a year and a half ago
right now I'm like diamond actually it's
a new season so I'm not even ranked yet
but last season I was Diamond what is
Pokemon's nationality I was born in
Morocco I lived there until I was four
years old little baby and then we
immigrated to Canada I lived there until
I was about 2021 and then I moved to LA
and you know what maybe I'll move again
soon doing the world tour okay
that was so weak I'll do the next one
harder
does pokemane
like Pokemon no actually I named myself
after that because I hate it no of
course I think I've never met someone in
the world who doesn't like Pokemon I
feel like that would be a really big red
flag I don't play it as often now as I
did Growing Up but it's one of those
things where like you know it's near and
dear to my heart because it's so
nostalgic my favorite Pokemon is Evie
because it's like picking
seven eight answers in one is that
cheating I hope not does Pokemon still
stream I do just not as often as I did
before you know when I first started my
career it was like six days a week then
it was like five then it was four
consistent schedule and now it's like
three two times I'll see you when I see
you and I like you like that because now
I'm able to do so many other things
luckily but I still try to make content
regularly pursue some new things I have
some exciting projects can't tell you
yet I'm sorry
soon
does Pokey Play League not unless I'm
feeling severely depressed and I haven't
played in a while so that's a good sign
if you get it you get it and for
everyone else in this room don't worry
it's just one of those games it's very
intense but I had my face I will always
love it as the game that got me into
streaming don't forget your roots but I
just don't play that much nowadays does
Pokemon have tattoos this is actually a
really good question because I think
most people would maybe assume that I do
but I don't have a single one I love the
idea of tattoos I love people that have
tattoos but if I had one myself I know I
would love it for a few months and then
I'd be like get it off so instead I
really like to opt for henna tattoos
does Pokemon have a fortnight skin I
actually don't have a fortnight skin but
I have a fortnight dance it's like
the fortnite team reaches out and
they're like hey we want to partner on a
dance or remote with you and I just sat
and I brainstormed in my little room to
me it was kind of reminiscent of like
The Tick Tock dances that were going on
at the time I'm also not about to do a
freaking backflip I can't do a backflip
so that will forever be one of the high
points of my career like having
something in a game that represents you
especially a game that large that
popular and one that was so impactful to
my career it's just like truly truly a
bucket list item
I like that one
oh my God okay first things first how
you pronounce my name Iman Anis it's not
anus okay I have had too many people in
my life be like is that
no my last name is not butthole please
stop it where did Iman Anis go to
college I went to McMaster University I
studied chemical engineering I really
really like and recommend that school I
mean to be fair I've been out of school
for like four years so nostalgic feels I
think most universities in Canada are
pretty good so can Iman Ennis speak
Arabic Canada
so technically I speak the Moroccan
dialect of Arabic which isn't like full
on classic Arabic I can say most
sentences but maybe I won't remember
most words I tend to tell people I speak
two and a half languages you know French
English a sort of Arabic a sort of
little bit anyone who's you know ESL or
an immigrant probably gets what I'm
saying not 100 but like a little bit can
Iman Anis do magic what do you mean
actually can I the only kind of magic I
do is manifestation
sometimes I'll think so hard about
something I feel like I plan out exactly
how to get it that's what I consider
manifestation not necessarily wishing
something into existence but thinking
about it so hard that you recognize the
opportunity when it comes aside from
that I wish I really do wish
height six foot two
six foot three on a good day says my
Tinder bio no I'm honestly honest honest
honest I'm five foot three and three
quarters but I just say five foot four
because
three quarters who cares I think it's a
very nice average height
I'm very content with my life
[Music]
how is
this boy whoever's Googling that
okay honestly I'm pretty good today not
a lot of people ask so thank you I'm
doing so how to join Pokey I already
know what this is Discord Discord server
Discord server Discord server if you
want to join to join our community it's
discord.ggp if you're doing it for
malicious purposes I don't know how do
you join how old Pokemon where's the is
that's how I know it's little kids
looking this up I am 27 my birthday was
a month and a half ago I feel like I'm
at a good age it's like I've been
through my early 20s now I'm a little
more secure and hopeful for the future
what's next
a family who knows
probably not soon how much Pokemon
worth see net worths are kind of
complicated it's supposed to be how much
is in your bank account how much is your
are your assets worth and I feel like
net worths tend to be overestimated
because they don't consider La taxes so
I'm going to stick with priceless
[Music]
in fragot I'm actually the main
character the guy no actually sometimes
I wonder so many people have been like
oh I saw you in free guy I'm like you
guys don't think I'm like the the girl
actress because in free guy I'm just me
I'm literally playing me I don't know
how to act I play video games
I thought it was so cool that in the
movie instead of just hiring people to
act as the streamers they got actual
streamers to give our actual reactions I
feel like that was a sign that they
actually wanted to make a movie that
people who are Gamers like and think is
legit and it gave an authentic feel you
know who is pokey his brother actually
he was the reason that I got into gaming
because you know when you're the younger
sibling you see everything your older
sibling does and you're like
mom dad let me do that I honestly just
played all the games that he played and
when I wanted to become a streamer and
wanted to go full time I was able to get
him to help convince my parents that
what I was doing was legit you know
gaming is still one of the ways that we
stay in touch we play valorant together
he's played on my stream with me so many
other times maybe someday he'll stream
too normal keep an eye out for that who
is pokey in my math solution oh my God
this is really embarrassing to talk
about publicly okay there's a meme I
can't even tell you the whole meme
for sure
my queen
in my world
it's a very very cute meme it's
wholesome
is pokey
kid-friendly
sometimes if I were to give myself a
grade on that I give myself like a 70.
so 30 of the time no but
why does Pokey have wgm okay for those
that don't know this is a chest term it
means woman Grand Master it's a very
very high rank term and I was in a chess
tournament so they gave me that title
even though I'm like so far from being
like at that rank but they gave it to me
as a joke and I think people saw that
and they're like why does she have that
title it's a joke thank you to them
though makes people think I'm better
than I am
Pokey main gaming chair right now I have
a Herman Miller do I think it's
comfortable kinda I'm kind of
uncomfortable because my posture is so
good so I force myself to sit in it this
isn't the best but it's good for me and
before that I had like a random one of
those gaming chairs like the ones that
kind of look like racing chairs I
actually kind of like those I really do
they're like
they keep you so steady where is pokey
right now I am in Los Angeles on set
with wired
the search that I both liked and it
caught me off guard was how is Pokemon
like does someone out there really want
to know that's really nice that's really
nice thank you so much I'll see you guys
in the next one bye